if you have unlimited migration and if
the numbers get out of control then it
is more difficult to bring people to
Britain make sure they have the schools
and the homes and the hospital beds and
the other services that are needed and
that's why we've always believed
controlled immigration and better
integration and a stronger Society go
together but the external thing is she
seemed to be criticizing her own record
as Home Secretary and potentially yours
as Prime Minister
well immigration is too high Teresa may
believes that I believe that the truth
is that we've done well when it comes to
migration from outside the united by the
european union and we've cracked down on
things like bogus colleges we've closed
around 800 of them which really weren't
colleges at all but because we've
created more jobs than the rest of
europe put together we have seen a large
amount of migration from inside the EU
now the way to answer that is to reform
our welfare system so you can't come
here and access benefits immediately but
secondly it's to educate and train and
make sure there are apprentices for our
own people which is why we're
introducing this skills levy so we
really upskill British workers it's one
thing to criticize migration it's
another thing to set a target and miss
it it's another thing to set a target
miss it and have a record and then
criticize your own record what I
wouldn't put it like that I'd say quite
right for the Home Secretary to say look
we've taken some important steps to
control immigration it isn't enough we
need to do better and let's remind
ourselves that there's a purpose to
controlling immigration which is it's
part of making sure we build a
integrated strong and cohesive society
is this the sort of message you want the
modern Conservative Party to put it out
there the Lib Dems and the IOD said that
this is a speech and that they decry and
you keep a welcome the speech is this
way you're positioning the future of the
conservative what I talk about is the
common ground the common ground with the
British people the British people want
to see not an end to immigration they
want to see controlled immigration and
that's actually I'm a message I received
from many in ethnic minority communities
in Britain as well
who are very passionate about this
subjects I think Teresa's speech
actually if you look at this conference
look at the big speeches from Boris
Johnson from Theresa May one of the
architects and the modernisation of the
Conservative Party from George Osborne
you
it's all been of a piece about building
more United more one nation a country
very much in the mold of what I would
call modern compassionate conservatives
why did you not make before the election
the case for cutting tax credits from
working families you asked repeatedly
and we didn't get an answer and now
you've done it
and people who voted for you didn't
expect their tax credits to become so we
made the case before the election that
you needed to reduce welfare because our
welfare budget was too big and we made
the case before the election that would
have to include working age welfare we
made that case very clearly in fact
before they when I became prime minister
9 out of 10 families in our country were
getting tax credits including MPs were
able to claim tax credits the system had
got too big and need to be brought under
control I think was interesting about
these new proposals that are passed
through Parliament is they're combined
with a national living wage that will
give the lowest paid people in our
country a 20-pounder week pay rise next
year not necessarily the same people get
them to the minimum wage rise aren't the
same people that get tax credit cuts and
the timing is different - well the
timing is the same actually because the
tax credits and the minimum wage both
national living wage come in in April
next year but the point about the
national living wage is that it helps
the lowest paid people in our country
the people currently on the minimum wage
will see that 20 pound a week pay rise
next year and it rising to 9 pounds over
this Parliament and of course the people
on the lowest incomes get the greatest
protection under our tax credit system
because they will keep the existing
award of the child tax credit some of
your MPs they made the case on the
doorstep you won seats facing the Labour
Party you want seats in Lib Dem areas on
the basis that they thought other
people's benefits were going to be cut
and not their tax credits are you
listening to your MPs and even Boris
Johnson we're concerned about this the
message we listening to our MPs but our
MPs voted for this in Parliament where
these measures were passed with a
majority of over 30 and when you think
that my majority is only 12 that
demonstrates that we won widespread a
core of support across there has the
comments for these changes and as I say
they're combined with the higher
national living wage and the tax
reductions that means you can earn
eleven thousand pounds before you start
paying any income tax at all